which is less the unit rate of the
equation y equals 6.5 X or the unit rate
of the graph shown below so when they're
talking about unit rate and they're
actually a little bit ambiguous here
there should have been clear in this
question they're really saying I'm
assuming they're asking us about the
unit rate at which Y changes with
respect to X or how much does y change
for a change of 1 in X the unit rate and
over here you see when X change is 1 Y
is going to change by 6 point 5 every
time x increases by 1 Y is going to
increase by 6.5 or you could say the
unit rate of change of Y with respect to
X is 6 point 5 for every one change in X
in this graph right over here as X
changes 1 as x increases 1 Y increases
it looks like about by about 3 and 1/2 x
increases by 1 Y increases by 3 and 1/2
so the unit rate of change here of Y
with respect to X is 3 and 1/2 for every
for every Y increases 3 and 1/2 for
every unit for every unit increase in X
so this line is increasing at a slower
rate than this equation or why Y in this
line is check is increasing at a slower
rate with respect to X then Y is
increasing with respect to X in this
equation right over here so the unit
rate of the graph is less than the unit
rate of the equation